One thing we can do to simplify this expression, is to start out by inserting
one new set of parentheses around this first 5 times 5. That way, just like
we've done before, we're multiplying two things together and we know how to use
the product rule in a situation like this. This is just going to be equal to
log base 10 of 5 times 5 plus log base 10 of 5. Conveniently, we've already
found this. That's what we got up here. Log base 10 of 5 times 5 is just log
base 10 of 5 plus log base 10 of 5. And then of course, we have to keep this
last, log base 10 of 5 added on to the end as well. Now we have three log base
10 of 5s added together. And this is just equal to 3 times log base 10 of 5, or
3 log base 10 of 5.